[Musique]
étrangère
étrangère [
Musique]
la forme du corps est longuement étirée,
sa tête est semblable à celle d'un chien, ce que
vous pouvez également voir, c'est qu'il a de
très petits yeux et un grand nez, donc il
était très agressif car il pouvait  je ne
vois pas bien,
il attaque toujours ici et il saute
dans les airs jusqu'à 15 pieds ou
plus
avec des pattes courtes et des ailes courtes et un
visage et des dents effrayants et effrayants,
il ressemble à un dragon,
il peut aussi voler,
vous devez être très prudent
surtout  quand il a faim,
c'est tellement toxique que même son souffle
peut tuer
[Musique]
ouais, une fois la lueur du feu, j'ai
détruit notre ville
[Musique]
donc si tu es attaqué, tu ferais mieux
de courir
[Musique]
déjà
les crocodiles sont trouvés ou  le président est
[Musique]
En fait, je crois vraiment que les gens
qui voient des choses étranges et des
créatures étranges voient ce qu'ils voient,
donc les gens qui voient une espèce étrange de
reptile ou qui croient avoir vu une
espèce étrange de reptile le feraient  ont
rapporté jusque dans les années 1930 qu'ils avaient
vu un tatsun où il y avait
des reportages réguliers sur les médiums des
blessures causées par les tatouages ​​et où les magazines scientifiques
demandaient à leurs lecteurs d'envoyer leurs
observations de salles de tatsule pour analyse
aux zoologistes.
L'idée qu'il existe de grands reptiles
de serpentine  ou la forme de lézard existe dans
toute l'Europe et vous avez un
terme général qui est Dragon qui vient du
mot grec draco qui signifie serpent
le mot germanique pour cela est charpie chaude
ou serpent serpent
euh en fait traduit et partout où vous
allez en Allemagne ou en allemand  Dans certaines
régions d'Europe, vous avez différents noms
pour le dragon et l'un d'entre eux est Turtle
War
[Musique]
les dragons sont
abordables
[Musique]
imaginez dans le passé
non seulement au moyen âge mais aussi
jusqu'à la fin du 19ème
siècle,
la nature à cette époque était  encore quelque chose de
dangereux quelque chose de très étrange
qui
est
quelque chose contre les êtres humains
[Musique]
mais néanmoins les gens devaient marcher d'
un endroit à l'autre errant d'
une vallée à l'autre Traversant des
montagnes et de telle manière une
errance solitaire j'imaginais qu'ils entraient
en contact  soudainement avec une telle créature
et le cas le plus intéressant pour
moi était en 1899 lorsqu'un
forestier officiel en
Autriche a rapporté qu'il avait été
attaqué par une tortue dans un
manteau de fourrure très lisse,
le kadu qui est un ver
est
[Musique]
[  Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
depuis ma petite enfance je
m'intéresse à la cryptosologie qui est un
mot grec désignant les
signes d'animaux cachés, des animaux encore
inconnus de la
zoologie
et alors que la plupart des cryptosologues
s'intéressent à savoir si ces animaux sont
réels ou non ou  essayez de les chasser. Je suis plus
intéressé par les implications sociologiques et
folkloriques de ces rapports,
alors que partout en Europe, vous trouvez le mythe
selon lequel il y avait des dragons dans les temps anciens
et il existe de nombreux termes et noms pour
ces dragons. En Allemagne, le dragon était
souvent appelé  lint womb qui est un vieux
mot allemand link signifie serpent et un
signifie aussi se produire, donc c'est le lindworm qui se
traduit en fait par serpent serpent
dans la région alpine, le lymphome était
souvent appelé tatsule qui est l'un des
nombreux noms locaux, d'autres sont des
backstruts mobiles australiens de ver noisette chaud
ou en Italie, le basilic,
quelque chose est la
nutrition des
observations des salles de tortues, c'est-à-dire des
gens qui prétendent avoir vu une
créature ressemblant à un dragon dans les montagnes,
se propageant dans toutes les Alpes, de
Nice en France
jusqu'en Italie autour des grands italiens
aime
partout  Suisse Autriche certaines parties de
l'Allemagne et de la Bavière et cela descend également
jusqu'en Yougoslavie où il y a encore
des variantes locales La
Géorgie
est
[Musique]
les gens les gens ne vivaient pas au
pied de Clarken il y a mille ans, ils
vivaient sur les collines donc dans la basa vous
vous auriez pu voir
celui lié, en général, les gens ont tendance à
penser que la salle des tortues est un animal
qui vit dans les rochers au-dessus de la limite des arbres,
mais d'après toutes les histoires que j'ai
rassemblées,
près de la moitié des histoires référencées
en ASL se sont blessées à proximité ou dans  de l'eau
où pratiquement aucune observation de
vers de tortue dans la forêt,
donc généralement
là où les gens s'attendent à voir des utérus de tortues
ou où les gens voient toucher les pièces, c'est
là que les gens diraient des lézards normaux, de
même que l'Allemagne a été déforestée et
s'est installée à mesure que le dragon était poussé
aux marges géographiques de la
région et celle où les lacs d'
une part et les hautes montagnes de l'
autre
[Musique]
les observations les plus récentes de
créatures ressemblant à des tatsuworms ont eu lieu dans la zone
des grands lacs italiens
qui entourent le lac de Côme  Garda et le
lac Marjora et dans le sud du Tyrone, à
la limite, j'ai fait Chevalier
et en Vénétie qui est la province
de Venise en Italie, les parties alpines de
cette province et en Autriche dans la
vallée des extrémités, donc si quelqu'un cherche de
véritables utérus de tortues vivantes, il  devrait
concentrer la recherche il y a
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] a été
trouvée au 14ème siècle
c'est Saint Michel à Tolfeld
um chez les dragons la soi-disant fosse aux dragons
au 13ème siècle le sceau de la ville de
Klagenfoot montrait déjà un ailé
dragon
le ver de tilleul
[Musique]
est étranger
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
existence [
est un mot allemand qui se traduit en
anglais par un serpent avec des pattes, ce qui
vous donne généralement une bonne idée de l'
apparence d'un tatsulum  comme
les gens qui les voient en ont parlé de nombreuses
espèces différentes, mais en général, c'est
soit un gros lézard comme un iguane, soit
un serpent et il y a eu des rapports de
chambres de taxi sans pattes, donc des
serpents complets ou seulement des pattes avant ou seulement des
pattes arrière ou même avec un  une rangée de pattes comme un
mille-pattes
étranger
[Musique]
ressemble souvent généralement à un lézard mais
avec une queue trapue, donc comme si la queue
était coupée, la peau ressemble à celle d'un
lézard ou d'un triton mais il y a de nombreuses
observations chaleureuses de Tatsu qui disent que c'est
celui que j'ai vu avait généralement des cheveux
dans les rapports modernes qui sont
plus crédibles en termes zoologiques, on
dit que la tête ressemble à celle d'un triton
, d'un serpent ou d'un lézard, mais il y a environ 200
ans, la chambre d'Hudson était toujours
lorsque les gens rapportaient  blessures totales, ils ont
dit qu'il avait la tête d'un mammifère, donc
principalement une tête de chat ou une tête de chèvre ou
une tête de chien ou même une tête d'enfant
[Musique]
l'histoire est que le ver à charpie vivait à
Clangford
et que les gens vivaient à l'extérieur de Clanford
parce qu'ils avaient peur du ver du tilleul
et celui de Tesla vivait dans cette
région
donc surtout la femme, ils avaient
beaucoup peur quand nous étions plus jeunes, quand nous avons
entendu l'histoire, nous avions un peu
peur du ver des charpies parce que quand il
avait faim, il a aussi mangé parfois
une des gentilles filles, je pensais que le
lindrom pouvait me mordre et me manger
et puis les hommes sont venus des
petits villages aux alentours
et un jour le prince de Clangford
a construit une tour contre
laquelle les jeunes chevaliers pouvaient se battre
la charpie et l'un des fermiers, il
avait
un bœuf, un bœuf fort
et ils lui ont mis quelque chose dans la bouche comme
quand tu vas à la pêche
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
étranger fondé [
Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
je l'ai fait  non seulement je lis des livres dans les journaux
et collectionne des informations sur ces monstres,
mais je voyage également dans de nombreuses régions où
des monstres ont été vus, également où
des salles d'église ont été vues et j'ai passé
quelques vacances en Italie où
les Italiens aiment les salles Tatsu ont été
bien signalées.  jusqu'à il y a cinq ans
et euh, j'ai traversé les montagnes, mais
même si j'ai trouvé d'anciens rapports, je n'ai jamais
pu en photographier un moi-même. L'
une des choses les plus intéressantes que
j'ai remarquées est en revanche de dire que les
serpents de mer sont comme des monstres, un grand
pourcentage de  les rapports faisaient référence à des
animaux morts, soit environ 60 rapports sur 500 font
référence à la découverte d'un squelette ou à
la mort d'un ver tatoué,
mais le plus récent sur lequel j'ai enquêté
était le cas d'un Tatsu qui a été
tué dans les années 1980 à  Carlton dans le Tyrol du Sud
où un agriculteur a trouvé une pièce de Tatsu
qui était morte et parce qu'il l'avait écrasée
sur son tracteur
et cela a été collecté et
analysé plus tard par des zoologistes et s'est avéré
être un refuge pusek qui est un lézard sans pattes
qui vit dans les Balkans  dans ce qui
était la Yougoslavie, il était très proche d'
une ligne de chemin de fer, on soupçonnait donc que
ce
lézard des Balkans qui ressemble à un serpent, une
créature très étrange et de grande taille,
avait rampé sur un wagon de chemin de fer dans les
Balkans et était ensuite
sorti lorsque le train s'est arrêté à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Joseph à Carlton
et a donc été tué là-bas.
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique] [
Musique]
garde des animaux exotiques qui s'échappent ou
qui sont relâchés dans la nature. Il y
a certainement plus de chances que de vrais
animaux soient derrière certaines des
observations, mais en général, je le fais.  Je pense que
c'est
encore une question de perception.
Vers 1800, vous avez en
règle générale des métiers à tisser à trois mètres et vers 1930, vous
avez en règle générale des utérus à un pied et
je pense que c'est une confirmation très forte
de l'idée que tant que
les Alpes  comme l'habitat était pratiquement
intact par l'homme, il pouvait imaginer de
grandes créatures y vivant comme dans
des pays étrangers, d'autant que les
montagnes étaient explorées par les alpinistes
par les touristes,
l'idée d'un dragon de trois mètres vivant
autour du lac de Côme, par exemple, est devenue incroyable,
alors les gens avaient tendance à voir  les petits animaux
[Musique]
étrangers [
Musique]
[Musique]
le nom Arkansas
est le thème que nous avons décidé de montrer à notre
public avec environ 150 espèces et plus
de 2 000 individus que
nous
exposons sur notre terrain la plus grande
collection de la faune alpine  dans le
monde
et dans la mesure où je suis un naturaliste
et surtout intéressé par le comportement animal,
je crois en ce que je vois et ce que je sais,
l'histoire de l'utérus de la tortue est intéressante
mais c'est pour moi c'est un mythe c'est une
légende
et je pourrais  imaginez que nous ayons une contrepartie
biologique très basique
au ver de combat qui est
l'autel de la rivière que l'
auteur de la rivière vit principalement comme son
nom l'indique sur les rivières, les ruisseaux et
les étangs,
est plus ou moins
nocturne ou actif pendant l'obscurité
et son comportement me donne le  impression
que c'est la
figure réaliste de la salle des tortues
la loutre de rivière lève son corps pour
avoir une vue d'ensemble
il crie si quelque chose lui fait peur
elle siffle aussi si elle a peur et
en nageant en
plongeant et si pendant la parade nuptiale
un mâle est  en suivant la femelle,
cela donne l'impression d'un steak
et donc dans l'ensemble, ce comportement de l'
autel de la rivière
pourrait être une très bonne
image
pour l'idée d'une tortue.
[Musique]
Riviera
différents [
Musique]
importants
[Musique]
gens de la campagne  pays où ils erraient
Traversant des montagnes
ou parfois très isolés seuls la
nuit dans l'obscurité
et à cette époque,
même au 19ème siècle, la
nature était quelque chose d'étrange et de dangereux,
c'était quelque chose dont il fallait avoir peur
et
River Auto n'est en fait pas seulement une
rivière vivant dans les rivières mais  ou dans l'eau
mais il erre aussi d'une vallée
à l'autre donc en traversant des montagnes
il se peut que l'eau de la rivière
traverse le chemin d'un homme errant
étranger
[Musique]
il pourrait te mordre s'il est s'il a
peur s'il est dedans  un coin ne peut pas
s'échapper, il vous attaquera, il
vous mordra, il criera donc cet animal, je
pense,
montre beaucoup d'objets
qui appartiennent au soi
-disant ver de combat et le cas le plus
intéressant pour moi était en
1899 lorsqu'un fonctionnaire  Un forestier en
Autriche a rapporté qu'il avait été
attaqué par un tutsalom portant un
manteau de fourrure très lisse et que les tests avaient été faits et qu'il
lui crachait du poison et il
l'a frappé et l'a tué et lorsque plus tard
les scientifiques sont venus le récupérer, c'était le
pêcheur à la ligne de  un cerf
donc
pratiquement tout pourrait être transformé
en salle de tatouage si la peur ou l'
idée que cet animal existait
euh était considérée comme réelle, tout
pouvait se transformer en tatouage
observations
[Musique] Il
y a 500 ans,
les os et les crânes que les gens ont trouvés
pensaient-ils  c'est qu'il est lié à
des dragons ou à des créatures mythiques
étrangères au
soi-disant ver des paupières qui
n'est bien sûr pas une créature mystique mais il date
de l'ère glaciaire et c'est un rhinocéros laineux
donc euh à cette époque où ils ont trouvé la
créature
ils le pensaient  ce serait autre chose
parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas les dinosaures
et les robinets, mais après cela, en
1840, le paléontologue est venu dans la
ville de Klangford et a vu le crâne,
puis il a découvert que c'était le
rhinocéros laineux de la dernière période glaciaire, donc  il a
environ 30 000 ans, peut-être un peu
plus, mais nous pensons à 30 000 ans
et ce que vous pouvez voir clairement ici sur les
sites et ici aussi, c'est vraiment une
structure osseuse
si vous vous cassez un os aujourd'hui, c'est la même
structure aussi quand vous regardez  là-dessus, vous
pouvez entendre qu'il y a un os de neige,
c'est euh, de la graisse sollicitée, bien sûr, il
ne vit pas sur le bouclier de glace, mais il
vit autour des zones vitrées
avec les mammifères, mais ce n'était pas si
fréquent, mais vous pouvez également le voir.  qu'elle
a de très petits yeux et un gros nez et
à cause de ces faits, ils pensent que le
site était mauvais mais l'odeur était bonne donc
elle était très agressive car elle
ne voyait pas bien quand les gens de
Clagafort ont trouvé cette vache, ils n'ont vu que
la  partie supérieure parce que la mâchoire inférieure
est manquante, donc elle ressemble beaucoup plus à un
serpent que tout le reste, elle est également
très grande et n'a aucune similitude avec
d'autres animaux de nos jours en tant que
paléontologue et avec nos connaissances, nous
savons qu'il s'agit d'un rhinocéros si vous êtes
aller en Afrique et regarder les Winans
aujourd'hui, ils ont un Sumatra, ils sont très
similaires et ils sont
euh, ils sont liés donc ce n'est aucun
doute que c'est un vinyle et non un
linful
comme exemple de la façon dont ce processus pourrait
fonctionner si vous visitez le Lochness  et voir une
grande ombre sombre dans les vagues, même si
vous êtes sceptique, vous penseriez
en termes de monstre du Loch Ness. Les gens
ont des idées préconçues sur ce qu'ils
savent des médias et au cours
des siècles précédents, nous savions à travers le folklore
ce qu'il fallait faire.  attendez-vous en termes de
monstres
et il y a une chaîne Tendances pour
les monstres à être en marge de la
civilisation qui est la lance du dragon
rapportée en Allemagne partout
au Moyen Âge personne n'en avait jamais vu
mais on savait que les dragons y vivaient
et autant que l'Allemagne a été déboisée
et  s'est installé plus le dragon a été
repoussé aux marges géographiques de
la région et celle où les lacs d'
un côté et les hautes montagnes de
l'autre et dans les Alpes cette idée du
Dragon a pu survivre le
plus longtemps
je pense que le  les gens qui ont trouvé le
crâne au 14ème siècle
croyaient vraiment à la légende du ver de tilleul
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas qu'il s'agissait d'un
crâne de la période glaciaire d'un mammifère de
la période glaciaire.
Je dirais que les habitants de
Klagenforth étaient déçus.  ce
fait pour la première fois mais de toute façon le
crâne est venu au 1849 fondé un
Musée régional d'Histoire Naturelle et
plus tard au Musée régional de
Corinthie où vous pouvez encore le voir
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
nourriture que nous avons  environ 100 000 habitants
un peu moins et nous voilà sur la
place principale qui est le nouveau Square neuya Platz
en allemand et derrière nous nous pouvons le voir dans la
salle Lind qui est le symbole de notre ville
nous avons tous un lien fort avec la
droite Lindbergh  ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc le ver de tilleul ouais c'est pas si facile de
définir ce que c'est en fait tout le monde
dit que c'est un dragon que si tu vas
plus loin tu verras que le visage est
proche de craindre le lion merveilleux alors
tu peux voir le  les oreilles c'est comme un oiseau
au bout la queue ressemble à un
serpent et elle a été construite au 16ème
siècle la grande statue d'Hercule a
été ajoutée au 17ème siècle c'est un
étranger de l'Est
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
étranger
Allemagne
[Musique]
le monument du ver de tilleul à
la nouvelle place de Clarkford est un
fait intéressant, il s'agit d'environ six villes
et il montre le ver de tilleul avec cette
bouche ouverte et de la bouche sort une
fontaine
donc c'est très artistique et quand vous
regardez la queue, la queue torsadée du ver de
tilleul, c'est aussi le signe d'
un navire de haut niveau en sculpture
[Musique]
cette source de fontaine était aussi une
chose pratique, elle était utilisée pour l'
approvisionnement en eau  dans la ville
donc l'ensemble est un
signe très caractéristique du maniérisme romain
c'est une œuvre d'art très importante
quand nous sommes petits enfants, chaque classe
va à la charpie et la regarde et nous avons
appris l'histoire du ver de tilleul à
l'école
et  oui, je pense que pour les citoyens de
Langford, c'est aussi un symbole important
car c'est le symbole de notre ville,
donc les gens
doivent choisir ce qu'ils veulent voir en
premier, mais la plupart d'entre eux se rendent
d'abord à la nouvelle place où nous avons
notre bombe Tesla.  et puis réciter nous
allons nager nous allons dans un
musée nous allons faire du shopping ou
regardons où nous devons aller où nous
pouvons acheter un souvenir avec le bureau d'information
[Musique] étrangère de Tesla
et vous pouvez voir un  plein
de produits liés au ver de tilleul au ver de
tatouage et tu peux voir le stylo
c'est sur le T-shirt donc si on va plus loin
on peut voir la légende c'est écrit dans un
joli livre et tu peux voir le blason
de Kragenfoot avec  fond en duo à la
Tour Blanche c'est comme une marque que vous
connaissez donc
vous pouvez aller plus loin c'est aussi pour les enfants
vous avez le livre sur le dragon il est
décrit comme un dragon ici Souvenirs
d'enfants c'est très sympa de
vous emmener à  ton lit dors et pour
le chapeau Spotify
[Musique] [
Musique]
c'est
[Musique]
livraison
Je pense que c'est la combinaison la
combinaison est la ville le lac
et celui du pompon Je ne peux pas dire qu'une
personne vient à l'horloge et à pied seulement
pour  voir la salle des pompons et une personne
vient à Kragenfoot uniquement pour aller
nager dans le lac c'est la combinaison
qu'offre la nourriture clagan
[Musique]
étrangère
et nous avons le ver de charpie dans notre nom
parce que c'est un symbole pour clangfoot  et
notre restaurant est vraiment proche de la
stature du
garçon aux sabots de lintworm, c'est une chaîne de restaurants où vous
pouvez manger et boire de la nourriture typique de Munich
et oui, j'ai travaillé dans un cabinet dentaire parce que
c'est aussi typique des vidéos de Munich
[Musique]
donc en fait le monstre peut être vivant
parce qu'il y a quelques mois, il y a eu
une histoire très étrange, il y avait
des gars peut-être ivres et oui, ce qu'ils ont
fait, c'est qu'ils pensaient que le monstre
était vivant et alors ils ont essayé de
le réparer, non, ils ont grimpé sur le monstre
sur le  la queue et la queue s'est cassée donc
nous avons dû la réparer à nouveau, c'était
plus ou moins un cauchemar pour le ver de tilleul
et pour ces gars, c'est sûr,
[Musique] étrangère
là-bas, vous ne pouvez pas en être si sûr et
quand vous nagez, nagez bien
dans le lac et vous allez plus loin,
vous pourriez toucher quelque chose et vous n'êtes pas
sûr que ce soit le ver du tilleul, donc
parfois vous ne pouvez pas avoir peur,
disons comme cette
importance économique,
de nombreux touristes viennent ici pour voir le
relief parce que  cela rend Langford un
peu intéressant parce qu'ils veulent
connaître l'histoire de la salle des charpies
et veulent la voir
[Musique]
quand je serai plus grand et que j'aurai des enfants, je
leur raconterai l'histoire de la salle des charpies
mais je ne veux pas  qu'ils aient peur
Atticus
[Musique]
le boom de Tesla a aussi quelque chose
de spécial et un chaleureux
comment dit-on énergie
[Musique]
eh bien, si tu veux vraiment vraiment voir un
bar de tatouage alors je te donne le conseil, bois
d'abord du schnaps, ce qui est très
courant  ici dans la région alpine,
quand il est tard dans la nuit,
commencez à gravir les montagnes à travers
quelques petites rivières et écoutez
peut-être que vous l'entendez
et je parie que vous aurez peur et
c'est le verbe du titre
[Musique]
malgré tout mon scepticisme concernant le
toucher  de pièce que vous ne pouvez jamais, il serait
très imprudent d'exclure à 100%
qu'il y ait quelque chose comme le tatouage
chaud, c'est très improbable mais qui sait
et même si vous ne rencontrez pas de
pièce tactile, je suis presque certain que le
paysage sur le  les montagnes
de Corinthia vaudront bien la
visite avec ou sans une seule
observation
[Musique]
étrangère